let's say you were prime minister what
would you do number one you've got to
restore some trust and you can only do
that by just being a bit frankly with
people Richie soon accident sent an
email out last night to conservative
party members so we've got brexit done
we've taken back control of our borders
but that is just a lie the second thing
that you've got to do is you absolutely
have to find a way where people can get
GP appointments longer term obviously
one of the big problems we have is not
trading enough of our own people and
relying on immigrant labor the whole
time number three fundamental look at
the tax system you go back through the
history of mankind many of the periods
of War and Peace have actually been
caused by taxes the fourth thing is
people won't like this very much but um
we can't go on paying you more to sit at
home than we can you go to work that
welfare is gonna have to be cut
welfarism is making people sicker it
isn't making them better number five I
think a really good thing about our
military forces there are some great
threats out there in the world China
Russia I think the extent to which we've
run down our national defenses in this
country over the course of the last 12
years is utterly shameful there you go